we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P here is yet another
caller thinking it's time for me to get
corrected about the vaccine
listen to this
hey David listening to your show now
why you are doing some major back
pedaling on what you are guilty of with
regards to the vaccine I'm back pedaling
well that sounds interesting let's see
if the voicemail explains in what way
I'm backpedaling
and
air time of any
real debate any open dialogue any
scientific inquiry
for anything other than
this vaccine even now you're just
telling all vitamin D is good for
everything guys like that's
David go back in your own tapes I've
been saying all along the same thing
about vitamin D and you can hear use you
say anybody who says you need Vitamin D
is an anti-vaxxer literally never said
it should be shutdown should be canceled
that was you
my my suggestion to you uh to well my
suggestion to you is to criticize me for
things I've actually said sir kind of
repair your credibility yeah is play us
some clips of some stuff that you played
in 2020 2021 you know let's hear it
let's hear you get on and say see what I
said here I'm being a reasonable so
listen there has been no back pedaling
let's take these things one at a time
let's first talk about the vaccine the
first vaccine tailored to the original
covid variant very effective at
preventing infection and transmission it
was a really good vaccine not only at
keeping you out of the hospital and
alive if you got covid but it was a good
vaccine at preventing you from getting
coveted at all as the virus changed and
the vaccine started to be modified to
keep up with it the vaccines became less
and less and less effective at
preventing infection I at no point said
anything other than that to the point
where now the vaccine really is about
keeping you alive and keeping you out of
the hospital it is not a vaccine that is
preventing infection at this point in
time I hope we can get to one that does
at no point have I backpedaled and at no
point have I made a claim about that
that didn't match what was actually
happening in the real world as far as
vitamin D vitamin D
uh zinc vitamin C
Ivermectin uh hydroxychloroquine we
looked at all of these things and my
Approach early was we don't have
evidence right now that these things
prevent covid or our treatments for
covid as we gained evidence we learned
okay Ivermectin doesn't work we've now
we have a good test we have a good trial
and it doesn't work hydroxychloroquine
doesn't work vitamin C and Zinc don't
seem to do anything to shorten the
duration vitamin D does seem like it is
generally good for fighting off
infections all along from the very
beginning I said to everybody in my
audience
I supplement my vitamin D in the winter
months
even if it doesn't do anything to
prevent or help you get over coveted
specifically it is a good thing to
maintain an adequate level of vitamin D
and that continues to be what I say
there has been no backpedaling
whatsoever so please criticize me for
things I've said sometimes people
criticize me for things other hosts have
said and they're like oh I actually
heard that on a different show but I
guess it was David I don't know if it's
an honest mistake apology accepted I
know you're not going to apologize sir
but uh there has been no back pedaling
thank you very much we're going to talk
on the bonus show today
about the latest on student loan debt
relief we are going to talk about Iowa
legislators proposing a ban on same-sex
marriage I know it's 2023 this is not a
show from from 2013. it's 2023. that's
what they're proposing let's ban
same-sex marriage and we will talk about
the post office buying almost 10 000
electric vehicles and 14 000 charging
stations very interesting stuff all of
it on today's bonus show sign up at
joinpakman.com and get instant access